that is the simple reason why Ukraine
doesn't want any ceas fire anymore
because we know how it
[Music]
ends let me ask you first of all Richard
as far as Russia is concerned with so
much at stake in the current
circumstances how is peace to be
obtained because you seem to give the
impression that the only way to get
peace was dismantle capitalism but that
doesn't seem to be an immediate way of
dealing with the situation in Ukraine
well my first reaction is to say that it
is probably true that a transition from
capitalism to something better that
we've Leed for a long time has never
been an immediately available option so
we have never pursued it as such and
we've therefore had one war after
another so maybe the immediate solution
is really not what we ought to be
looking at we can find find and make
immediate adjustments but the effect of
the immediate adjustments we've made in
the past has hardly been to bring us
peace it's the point the last speaker
made that peace is simp not simply the
absence of War peace if it's going to
mean anything has got to have in it a
recognition and an attention to the
underlying forces of it otherwise we're
left with nostrums like it's better to
have more weapons than less really
that's a guarantee for peace to have
more weapons than less we have that here
in the United States we are a society
that has more weapons per person than
any place else on
Earth we don't have peace we have the
most violent domestic politics
imaginable as well as an armaments
beyond words for Global Warfare we
didn't bring peace to anyone by this
strategy but you you you made that uh
Point previously Richard powerfully but
what do you think in the current
circumstances uh should be done to
advance peace in the context of the
Russia Ukraine conflict are you saying
that the uh the West should not be
supporting Ukraine at all there should
be no weapons provided to Ukraine what
do you think should be actually
done well we had two conflicting
interests there we had the anxiety of
the West about what the Russians might
do and we had the anxiety of the
Russians about what the West Was likely
to do they had been maneuvering against
one another as was correctly said
earlier for many years milit arily in
the donbass in the area nearest the
Russian border and politically and
otherwise in all the usual intelligence
as well maneuvering that we know goes on
so the issue for me and I think a
reasonable way to approach it is to say
before you get to the point of the
threat of the basic interests of these
two sides that you sit down which was
done early in the conflict back in
February to try to come up with some
solution that might address the needs of
both sides so there is no war rather
than proceed Crossing each other you
know red lines as they like to call them
and then Pro one side provokes the other
and then to retreat into saying who
exactly provoked who when with what date
really that's childish the issue is what
are the fundamental concerns and those
have to be put on the table with a DE
Dem man that they be worked out without
military recourse okay I I'm still
unraid not quite sure whether you think
that there should in the in the interim
of coming to an agreement uh diplomatic
agreement with Russia you think there
should be support for Ukraine but let's
turn to S Lana what what do you think
about that uh diplomatic as it were
solution to
peace uh first of all Russia even now
they don't want to negotiate and they
repeat it a lot of times that they're
going they're going to have peace talks
only on their terms meaning that uh the
occupied parts of Ukraine that are are
right now under Russian control that we
they will remain Russian that Ukraine
will have to give up Crimea east of
Ukraine the parisia region but not only
that that Ukraine should never become a
NATO member and all of the other demands
that Russia has and when uh
we are talking about the negotiations
between the west and Russia I don't see
there Ukraine I mean the war is fought
in Ukraine and I feel like we are not
included at all like it it sounds like
everything has to be decided over us
that they will reach some kind of
agreement and but what will happen to
Ukrainian people who are living
occupation who are scared to leave their
houses because their women can be raped
that the kids that can't learn their
language was happen to all of those
people if those lands remained Russian
So my answer for that is Ukraine has to
receive uh the military and financial
support to win the war in a military way
if it is not enough uh to win the war if
you receive not enough like now Ukraine
at least have to be in the better
position before negotiations it has to
have certain leverage to talk with
Russia for example if we receive long
range missiles and we uh seize Russian
army in Crimea and uh destroy the car
bridge then we can talk with Russia
about something or we destroy their
Fleet because right
now both sides won't negotiate because
Russia of course won't leave Ukraine's
land and Ukraine won't give up its
territories and its people so Richard
you you're you're not taking into
account the interest of the ukrainians
in suggesting a negotiation between uh
the west and
Russia of course I am that that's the
kind of debate that that goes nowhere
finger pointing it's your fault no it's
your fault it's
childish of course Ukraine's interest is
in my mind the horror of the war that is
being fought mostly on their territory
is self-evident they are suffering
unspeakably and they should not have and
the responsibility for that is
largely distribut
all across the participants ukrainians
Russians Americans British and fill in
the blank they all have a responsibility
all of them to participate in a
negotiated settlement that takes into
account the the needs the genuine needs
of the Ukrainian people the Russian
people and the Western countries that
have inserted themselves into this
Arrangement well they may they may all
have a responsibility but spit Lana's
point is that the Russians aren't going
to take that responsibility they're not
going to take into account the interests
of the ukrainians and what do you do
what do you propose that you do in a
situation where one party is simply not
prepared to take into account the
interests of the other well we don't
read the history the same the Russians
feel that they have not had their
security interests taken seriously by
the NATO Powers by the United States
stes and Britain that guaranteed them
certain protections with the end of the
Cold War Etc I'm not here to negotiate
or to arbitrate among these different
perspectives but I don't think it gets
us one step closer to peace to spend our
time deciding who's the good guy and
who's the bad guy this stuff happens in
every war and mostly what it does is
obscure the
underlying Productions of this
why did NATO move to the east why was
that a useful thing to do in the
interests of world peace that's just as
important as what happened in the
donbass over the last eight years all of
those things are reflections of
underlying social processes here's the
irony we didn't have a war in Europe by
en llarge during the Cold War but as
soon as the Cold War was over guess what
what we began a series of processes
ending up in the Ukraine war we have to
understand why that happened rather than
getting lost in the specifics that it
was Ukraine rather than country X or
country why having a large country
invade and take over a small country
that's not new that's not uniquely
Russian it's got nothing to do with it
I'm a citizen of a country that is very
large and very powerful and very rich
our lovely history over the last 30 40
years has been to invade the poor
backward country of Korea the poor
backward country of Vietnam of Iraq of
Afghanistan I mean I could go on but we
are not having big discussions on who's
the good guy and who's the bad guy we
want to take a step back and ask how and
why do these things keep Happ happening
rather than getting all up on a
bizarre Soap Box to tell us who's in the
right and who's in the wrong on this
latest version of a very old story
DAV I think we've got to come back to
the position we're in now where the
aggressor in my view Russia uh after all
president presid Putin is on record he
said Ukraine is a sovereign independent
nation state and it will choose its own
path to peace and
security those were not words he kept to
um but we're in a position where the
aggressor Russia has is showing no signs
whatever of recognizing the mistakes
that have been made in its uh military
operation uh of recognizing the
humanitarian cast history that it's
creating of recognizing it is not
fighting this war according to
humanitarian law
principles so you can argue as much as
you like with Moscow there is no sign at
the moment that their losses are
sufficient to uh cause a change of heart
the the victim the immediate victim
there is no sign that the Ukrainian
people are prepared to throw in the
towel and say we give up uh we will
surrender to uh moscow's demands so
that's the position we've actually got
to start with and at some point
something will change I don't know what
it will be whether it will be in Moscow
uh whether it will be on the battlefield
and
then settlement talks can begin I would
personally be very unhappy to see simply
calls from for a
ceasefire because all that does is give
both parties the chance to take their uh
to catch their breath to rearm and the
war will start again what President
Putin has very publicly said is that
Ukraine cannot be now he's now said
Ukraine and cannot be an independent
state it is part of the Russian
Empire until then
mindset changes this war is not going to
end so you were advocating therefore the
support of the West for military uh arms
to Ukraine are there any limits to that
how how much uh arms does the does the
West provide and coming back to our big
overall theme is is the provision of
military defense the way to gain peace
is that in the end is it going to be is
peace only going to be obtained by
having sufficient uh military force on
one side to deter the other which is
Fan's
point the collapse of
Ukraine under Russian pressure is not
will not result in what I would describe
as peace with Justice therefore it
follows that Ukraine must be enabled to
continue to resist uh so does that mean
there's no limit to the amount of
weapons any more than that we say we
take the Russian view there's no limit
and the atrocities we can commit we have
to operate under International
humanitarian
law and there are restrictions there and
we have to look after if you like the
interest of our own people which is why
acting in a way that could lead to
escalation with Russia a full out war
between NATO and Russia would be a
catastrophe so we have to take steps to
minimize that risk and that's very
uncomfortable for our Ukrainian friends
because it means that for example
limitations are placed on longrange
weapons that might be supplied that
cannot be used to attack Russia itself
in case that is misunderstood so this is
a nasty
uncomfortable position for everyone okay
but we I just
to pick up one point Richard made it is
possible to draw a very different
history from that that Richard briefly
outlined and you won't want me to do it
here because we haven't got the time but
I just urge people just don't jump to
the conclusion that for example uh NATO
taking in new members which is it was
entirely legitimate for NATO to accept
new members those new members want to
join the European Union where they
haven't already joined it was that
something to be denied
them because Russia felt that somehow
this was to expand the zone of European
uh
civilization and Putin himself has
declared himself an enemy of
Europe and he wishes to
resist uh uh what he would see as
European influence inside Russia now I
find all this almost
incomprehensible when I hear Putin talk
and read what he says but that is the
truth that's where we currently are but
let me simply comment since I'm
astonished too at the argument that we
ought not to have a ceasefire because it
would give time to the two sides each of
them to arm some more Etc that's always
true that has always been true it has
been the context of every ceasefire
negotiated and for every example that a
ceasefire was used to arm further
there's an example in which a ceasefire
was the first step into ending a war and
conflict it's if you don't want to end
the war in conflict that you lopsidedly
suggest that the ceasefire could have
negative consequences it's always true
with any proposition that it could have
negative consequences I wouldn't deny
that that's possible but for you or
anyone to suggest that we oughtn't to
explore a ceasefire surrounded by the
normal qualifications that go with
ceased fires reject that out of hand
while people are dying on the streets of
Ukraine strikes me as a remarkable
unwillingness to deal with the basic
issues because in fact we are lost in
our conflicting Notions of what the
history was that reinforces the argument
that it's the underlying historical
forces that we ought to be addressing
rather than getting lost in the quidd
Pro but that's because
very
simply that is because in the historical
cases you would site the ceasefire was
the first step to a settlement as I've
been trying to explain at the moment we
do not have the conditions which allow
would allow for a proper settlement and
therefore that's why Simply Having a
ceasefire to try temporarily to Halt the
Bloodshed is not I think the answer I
would like to add just one thing think
we had a ceas fire ceasefire with Russia
for eight years that the West pushed us
into and for all of these years when the
West was thinking there is peace in
Ukraine our soldiers kept dying because
Russia didn't keep their Promises of not
keep of of keep of keeping the ceas fire
uh people civilians kept dying they just
gathered more weapons and came and
invaded us again that is the simple
reason why Ukraine doesn't want any ceas
fire anymore because we know how it and
okay let's let's move on to to a next o
overall theme in trying to address the
question of how we pursue peace and
that's to look at the nuclear deterrent
in general to continue watching this
video click the link in the top left or
in the description below or visit I a.tv
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest
ideas